come
ol se
que OB
empura
bom que boa boa Eu sou Eu que sou
doido de um Casal sempre Tem um que é o
maluco é Ou sou Eu descobri is Eu OSS
Nisa nem Fazer
o
diagnosticada empurra Paula empurra
é T bom buscamos um problema achamos
bioquimica achamos n bioquimica
olha Meu déficit de mentil Como déficit
de
mentil Ela Tem sei Ela Tem Uma muta de
um de um GMT hfr né metileno tet folato
rutas acha que acho que respondo desse
essa Condi acho
que acho que responde no no Mas por Isso
Ela nasceu Assim
SIM SIM vemos T da estrutura estrutura
bom T
Doo toos os dedos todos os dedos todos
os dedos Esse qual que é mesmo terreno
terreno terreno empurra é terreno
terreno Biolo Esse é o problema de
terreno Ah o genético é terreno muitas
vezes é terreno Porque o terreno é a
Nossa
simica nostra
V qualquer problema qualquer V
[Musica]
Isso
V da digestione é digerente
respirat pronto certo a s s Certo certo
o
terren
Imp cicatriz
cicatri se
l Tudo Bem Ur B
deico
biochimico
ancora
eo
fiscia per esempio no
e no
e
AA
test da capza
test Prim no Prim
capezza Allora capezza ma SP
Fren
flexo
in
capza
Rot no
SCH
inclin
SC
Bu m non e important
variazione no sì serv Sì ma non è non è
da come si Chama
corta fatura fatura OSS tanto tranto
odontoide che molto
importante rante tessi da
lingua Ani Eh sì sì lingua lingua lingua
non scav
però aperta non
aperta
bus Max
lingu italiano lingu non
sai questo
tti
Depo
che massima prod
lingua
ok
secondo de
CR de
impura pronta
vi
bronto
bti
fai
Ok levanta
l
problema é tocando
bom
olos impur bom problema perfeto essa l
problema
de de espa
Vente
D problema
S Os testes da cabea para ver O que
que Jon atlant oito oidea Ess boa boa é
Porque
é passa Gro ATL
odontoide quem anota atlant od
odontoide
Mas todas as poses de cabea era para ver
Isso Ou S Uma
delas srias poses de cabea
hiens todas essas poses é relacion
Isso o
Tem
dire na
verdade para Bu do
Sado inclinado
positivo che re consulta siica negativo
[ __ ] positivo significa
Sias se fac placca
qualche Continua continua
de
F problema Sì m
importante
se problema
permanese
Stud Il problema è odontologico solo
pric un problema strutturale un problema
di colunna non è solo
odontologico
tut eo che important SAP
Sì consig speg perché
fta
prx captos pode ser qualquer coisa Mauro
quer saber o nome da Jun Atlantico ATL
atlanto oxp Ah at Atlanta italiano
desculpa ADR oito o donide oit Porque
Atlanta italiano desculpa Eu pensei Isso
Ah atras oxito atras oxito ideia ideo
atras
oxito certo o é com 21 anos que que
aparece processo an
é atas
né o do freio é para avaliar
o o do
freio Ele Fe
essa ve Allora
rusio vai
prta È la seconda
vertebra
daas
eun è
adas
adess noci che
sta
impato
contas Esiste un Esiste un legamento
legamento
sta funzionando
problema
èun sta soffrendo
sempre soffrendo perché è punto di
passagg è passaggi deste o corpo
superiore o corpo inferiore non sai se
possiamo intendere cioè come porta sta
come si
chiama e mesmo e ommo è un punto di
passaggio duen Cenza che seend dis
senden passano
F
esio un
lato un
lato
quando
no Si apaga e fcio b significa che sta
sbagliando non se o
Crus e si Vai Recupera la funzion
originaria Recupera punzione originaria
nostro fig funzione
originaria nome
da la
funzione doad
doad doad doad desculpa
doad ok
primaa o teste do freio lngua né qual
signific del positivo
allora
significo é
lì un problema un
problema Sao come che un
problema perché Mus
forof
non
per non
se problema
possib Sì
problema Bas
[Musica]
spaz spaz
lingua spazio ventr
spazio
Sempre
pus problema di lingua con
f poso significa che
quando e Impa lingua spazio vaso muscol
forte F FR segn una sofferenza
sofferenza lingu che non è della lingua
è duas
duas ofio
percho
molimo
es
classe
bocca
bua br
noch
perché ctoa lingua non buon
movimentazione non Consi Irno palato
cons SP spci Palatino che sta non cons
F
lingua
leg presa pres Culpa è un problema serio
visto per perché la postura di di un
pazien Curto è come la postura di
gallina MMA
detto
SP è
forte forte
secondo
secondo condiz desolve una Come si
chiama una
malous
certeza ent temos que avaliar se Vamos a
Fazer a cirurgia Ou se pusar o Dedo No
no freio e [ __ ] O mculo que era forte
[ __ ] fraco significa que Tem alum
problema que pode gerar occlus SIM se
problema estamos calhar melhor Fazer
cirurgia tratar do freio C freio do
freio do freio Tem Leite é muito Cas
Isso é muito SIM S Mas por exemplo
eh
Sì
perch
nostro intendimento compito nostro
compito
comprens
obit futuro s preven
n